[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on doit les années on va mettre le mot
vanille est allé sur le thonier à 12 ans
l'autre à l'ennemi chacun a levé lors la
visite mettez-vous dessus
ça c'est sûr la pop la trêve allait
passer allez-y bonera levée mettez-vous
dessus suisse à l'origine c'est vous la
noël adieu la baisse que c'est vanille
est-ce que c'est bas n'y aura pas qu'un
téléspectateur qui peut gagner un cadeau
magnifique sac des mains doit de briques
je le rappelle en effet il s'agit donc
de la toute nouvelle console de jeu qui
sera normalement près de cas partir du
21 juin
je pars m'a dit au micro de jeu c'était
faire attention que manny est le bon mot
ce temps tu peux pousser 7e place jeu
dans le savoir regarder en direction du
fort tous attention
mais ça marche pas steppas condamnation
même temps
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les chiens et merci fort boyard ce sera
chouette headache olivier minne magloire
willy rovelli toute la bande
si toi
saïda regard est ce que peut avoir la
séquence avec isa s'il vous plaît qu'on
a mise à vals à voir vale faire un gros
bisou n'est pas moi c'est l'amitié plus
de vingt ans quand même nom mais je sais
[ __ ] temps regardez on peut revoir la
séquence je voudrais l'armoire parce que
c'est la seule qui passe devant le my
way ce fou rire alors non pas voir le
sont souples et lotions on veut le son à
fond la gomme s'élève pas voir le sont
merci remettez au début
[Applaudissements]
beaucoup
quand les gens partent il arrive je te
dis que je tenais avec moi frais a
laissé ton portable au coup tu te calmes
c'est la première fois qu'il veut
vraiment m'appelait mon frère
[Applaudissements]
camel meriem
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors c'est le cordage de marc germain
castano maintenant alors tu n'as jamais
je vois nos codes alors benjamin je vais
suivre regarder ton portable pour
l'instant je suis bien sûr tu te
comportes mal je verrai ce que j'en fais
rien pour moi mais il s'est bien
comporté comme ça va bien la canebière
qui a eu cette idée je trouverai les
responsables et je veux du scénariste
complètement ses conseils en tout six
médecins avaient trouvé dans un instant
[Applaudissements]
guay
l'essai
[Musique]